A new discovery into how our cells work might
be able to restart our age!
But you'll have to get some cells from you
as a baby... so... that might be tough.
Hey gang, Trace here for DNews.
We are all getting older from the moment we're
born.
Eventually, we'll all die.
But HOW we get there and the upper LIMIT of
human life is the subject of a study in Genome
Research published last week.
The researchers got ahold of blood from one
of the oldest known humans, Henny van Andel-Schipper.
She was the oldest person in the world when
she died in 2005 at the age of 115, wow...
that's... that's pretty old.
She was born in the 19th century and lived
til the 21st.
Anyway, aging is a pretty complicated process,
but in essence scientists believe it has to
do with telomeres.
Telomeres are sort of like the tips on the
end of your shoelaces, but for chromosomes,
they maintain your genetic material and keep
it from mixing with other chromosomes.
Over time, the telomeres shorten, which causes
what's called somatic mutation.
It happens naturally over time, it's completely
normal.
Apparently, Ms. Van Andel-Shipper was an organ
donor, because doctors were able to collect
tissue from her brain, blood, kidneys, arteries,
liver, lung heart, spleen, aorta, and even
a breast cancer tumor she had when she was
100! Way to go Henny!
The telomeres in her brain were similar in
length to those of a newborn, because brain
cells don't divide that often; but telomeres
in her red blood cells were 17 times shorter!
The doctors figured her blood genome had gone
through at least SIX HUNDRED mutations over
her lifetime, maybe more!
Basically, what happens is as the blood cells
are created from stem cells, new stem cells
have to come up to replace them.
We're born with about 20,000 stem cells to
do this job.
Over time, the stem cells mutate -- because
telomeres -- but just like in X-Men, mutation
can be good or bad.
Sometimes we get a good cell, and other times
we get cancer.
We don't ever get telepathy... at least not
yet... anyway...
So as Ms. Van Andel-Shipper aged, her stem
cells divided and divided and mutated and
divided.
By the time she was old, most of her white
blood stem cells could be traced back to TWO
mother cells.
This indicated most of those 20,000 had burned
out or died.
She was running on fumes for a long time...
Eventually they just... burned out.
Knowing ALL these things, why can't we give
her a refill?
Obviously, we can't UNmutate the thousands
of generations of Henny's blood, because...
a copy of a copy of a copy is never as good
as the original.
But what if we had the original?
What if when we're born, stem cells are removed
from our brand-new bodies and saved to start
the stem-cell telomere shortening over; like
hitting the reset button on aging!
Maybe there's something to that "bathing in
the blood of young virgins" thing...
Anyway, lots more research is needed, but
this is the first time every somatic mutations
have been studied in such a way, and it can
teach us a lot about how the human body ages,
why, and what we can do about it.
What do you think?
What would you do if you could live for 200
years?
Tell us below because we really do read the
comments and make sure you subscribe for more
DNews every day of the week!
If you' like me are a little skeeved out by
biology stories and nature stuff you should
totally check out my friend Catie Wayne's
show Weird, Gross and Beautiful -- they wanted
to call the show Weird and Gross, but she
was all like, "NO WAY!," because if you look
even nasty nature things are pretty... somehow.
Watch it to find out how!
Thanks for tuning into DNews, you're all the
bestest, come find me on twitter at-tracedominguez
and say hi!